so we are watching Lindsay here was
demonstrating the hearthstone running on
the iPad but she's kind of demonstrating
here just kind of how you can basically
the game is essentially very similar
it's kind of what it was on the PC from
the standpoint that anything you learned
in terms of how the cards work how the
various mechanics of the game work are
all things that are available here in
the iPad version as well it's basically
as easy is just dragging around in terms
of targeting which menus you want to
attack dragging cars out of your hand to
be able to get them into the game space
and the idea here was that if you are
coming from previous versions of the
game you just intuitively know how to
interact with the cards that's that was
the goal of the team as we were sort of
working on the overall development
effort so kind of see here she's beating
up on that core palette and at the top
all the elements on the board are still
interact a lot of clickable are there
again one of the things that's exciting
is you're using your same account on
both iPad and PC so what I might be
doing is in the morning I might play on
the PC and start an arena run and in the
afternoon I'll finish that arena run off
on my iPad so I can just switch back and
forth well done and so in this case
Lizzie just finished up a quick friendly
game you can dump the matchmaking pool
between PC and iPad is also shared so
that if somebody jumps on a PC and you
happen to be on an iPad you'll have
every bit of a chance of match against
those people and we think that'll be
really great for the game in that you'll
have a much wider pool people can be
matched with so another can kind of show
off here's maybe just a opening up a
pack and you know wanted to keep that
experience feeling very physical and
tactile as you're dragging cards into
play and open up a pack
and we went on there's the the rare okay
let's see what it is okay we've got a
flair awesome so and then naturally go
ahead move into the collection manager
and get a feel for what that experience
is like as well you know one thing
that's been great is that the game was
built to be very physical for the PC
version and that physicality has helped
a huge amount in the iPad and it's even
more physical when you're actually
touching the cards and dragging it to
your deck and dragging and to play using
your finger yeah totally so there's a
case we can just drag cards back and
forth to actually add them to your deck
we are right now in the middle of the
launch for our Sun on the iPad we've
launched at this point in Australia New
Zealand and Canada all the results from
that have been coming back very in terms
of very good results so right now we
don't see any major roadblock issues and
so we're looking forward to releasing
this now globally within the next week
or so